the Audi rs5 is a happy car
see it's big open grille the slight
upward tilt of its headlights it's high
smooth sides that blend back to an
almost non-existent rear it smiles when
you drive it
this is Audi's $71,000 sport coupe
revved up far more than its standard s5
and it cost $20,000 more - it has a 450
horsepower v8 engine and Audi's
trademark Quattro four-wheel drive the
overall effect is athletic to say the
least I might even say frisky which is
perfect for me it's nearly spring after
all one of my favorite things about
outtie is how recognizable its cars are
even from a distance the badging on the
rs5 also marks it as special the bold
red stripe along its baseboards steering
wheel and rear lets everyone know that
you've got the fastest version available
inside I love the auto dimming mirrors
nappa leather heated seats and the wide
adjustable sunroof there are 14 speakers
with Bing and Olufsen sound and there's
room for 4 passengers but back to the
driving the suspension on the rs5 is
super tight and the brakes are too the
7-speed dual-clutch transmission is
smooth and quick the opposite of fussy
and the whole thing feels nimble both
around corners and off the line in fact
the worst thing people usually say about
outtie sports cars is that while they're
nearly perfect they have no real
personality no soul but I disagree this
little coupe is powerful pretty and
poised
it's not shallow it just wants to have
fun